This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个IHeart播客。Guaranteed Human。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说都是个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是Sam J.。我是Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在Outer、My Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kier Games主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人群体的体验，进行那些在其他地方绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的有证专业人士交谈。有多少男人背负着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hard Way。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
在2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星Clayton Eckerd被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次并在出售，对吧？我伪造了测试一次。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。Greg，一个男同性恋者，Michael Mancini。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
我是Stephanie Young。这是Love Trapped。Laura，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，Laura Owens终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody.
在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，建立精神坚韧性、健身和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即TWO percent。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。
Before we get into it, I just wanted to pop in here and let you know that this episode will deal with some pretty extreme concepts around disordered eating, weight gain, and weight loss. If this is something that is triggering for you or may upset you or you just aren't in the right mental headspace to hear it, please feel free to skip this episode and return to it later on. We will also have resources below. if you are looking for some extra help.
在我们深入探讨之前，我只是想插播一下，让你们知道这一集将涉及一些关于饮食失调、体重增加和体重减轻的相当极端的概念。如果这些内容会触发你的焦虑、让你感到不安，或者你现在的心态不适合听这些，请随时跳过这一集，以后再听。如果你需要额外的帮助，我们也会在下方提供相关资源。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. So I have a feeling that today's chat is going to be a big one
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们在此剖析二十岁的心理学。所以我有预感，今天的聊天将会是一个大话题
because honestly I have been wanting to talk about this topic for, some time. You can obviously probably feel my passion or rather, I'm going to know, like frustration already coming across. But before I did so, I wanted to just like sit with my thoughts for a little bit, have some reflections, talk to the trusted advisors. I also want to thank our research assistant Lee Be Colbert for her help on this episode and a friend of the show, Erin Somerville, who is an assistant psychologist and therapist that works with people who have eating disorders, her opinions and thoughts were so valuable. So big shout out and thank you to Erin and Libby for helping with this episode today. But basically, as I said, I wanted to,
因为说实话，我一直想聊这个话题有一段时间了。你大概能感受到我的热情，或者更确切地说，我已经能感觉到沮丧情绪扑面而来了。但在我这么做之前，我想先沉淀一下自己的思绪，做一些反思，并与值得信赖的顾问交流。我还要感谢我们的研究助理Lee Be Colbert为这一集提供的帮助，以及节目之友Erin Somerville，她是一位助理心理学家和治疗师，专门与有饮食失调的人合作，她的意见和想法非常有价值。所以在此向Erin和Libby为今天这一集提供的帮助表示巨大的感谢和敬意。但基本上，正如我所说，我想，
I wanted to make sure that my thoughts were coherent and in the right place. Today, of course, we are talking about Skinny Talk. You likely have seen things about this if you are at all online. It is basically a social media hashtag, social media trend. glorifying, distorted eating and unhealthy habits behind the guise of how good it feels to be skinny and how you can do it yourself. Now at first glance, you might think that this looks like harmless training tips or meal inspo or body positivity for naturally thinner people out there. It's actually so much more complex and layered than that. And one of the most dangerous intersections between body image, social media, gender,
我想确保我的想法是连贯的并且在正确的轨道上。当然，我们今天要聊的是“瘦身言论”（Skinny Talk）。如果你在网上冲浪，你大概率已经见过相关内容了。这基本上是一个社交媒体标签，一种社交媒体趋势。它以“瘦下来感觉多好”以及“你也可以自己做到”为幌子，美化失调的饮食和不健康的习惯。初看之下，你可能会认为这像是无害的训练技巧、饮食灵感，或是针对天生较瘦的人的身体积极性。实际上，它比这要复杂得多，层层交织。
disordered eating that I've seen in a long time. And I say seen in some time or seen in a long time, because if you are of a certain generation, you have most certainly seen this before. I don't know if you guys grew up on Tumblr or the side of Tumblr that I grew up on. But back in the day, what, like 2014, back in the day, it was literally a free-for-all on the most, like,
这是我见过的身体形象、社交媒体、性别以及饮食失调之间最危险的交汇点之一。我说“一段时间以来见过的”或“很久以来见过的”，是因为如果你属于某个特定世代，你肯定以前就见过这种东西。我不知道你们是不是看着Tumblr长大的，或者像我一样看着Tumblr的某个角落长大的。但过去，大概2014年左右，那里简直是一片混乱，充斥着各种极端的、类似于
heinous tips and tricks to basically become as skinny as possible as fast as possible. It was at the time when like those detox teas were like huge. How long until we figured out that those were basically just laxatives? That's like a whole story for another time. And you know, on these sides like being skinny was romanticized as this like fix for all of your problems. I remember so many black and white images of thigh gaps, rib cages, crazy waistlines. and Skinny Talk, it's just a whole new version of that in different packaging.
如何以最快速度变得尽可能瘦的可怕秘诀和技巧。当时那些排毒茶简直火得一塌糊涂。我们花了多久才发现那些其实只是泻药？这又是另一个长篇大论了。而且你知道，在这些地方，瘦被浪漫化为解决你所有问题的灵丹妙药。我还记得那么多关于大腿缝、肋骨、夸张腰围的黑白照片，而“Skinny Talk”不过是换了个包装的全新版本。
And what's so dangerous about it is that it's a lot less easy to spot as it perhaps probably was in the past. So this is what I want to explore today. I want to dive into the ways that we can understand what content is Skinny Talk aligned and what is not, the crossovers with disordered eating and what this trend towards extreme thinness is really saying about society more broadly and more psychologically. Where is this all coming from? Of course, we're also going to finish up on some ways that you can counteract Skinny Talk in your own life. I obviously want to finish this episode with some hope rather than despair. But yeah, it's going to be a big one. With that all being said, I hope you are ready. Let's get into.
它最危险的地方在于，它不像过去那样容易被发现了。所以这就是我今天要探讨的内容。我想深入探讨我们如何识别哪些内容属于“Skinny Talk”，哪些不是，它与饮食失调的交集，以及这种追求极端苗条的趋势对更广泛的社会和心理真正意味着什么。这一切究竟是从哪里来的？当然，我们最后也会探讨一些如何在日常生活中抵制“Skinny Talk”的方法。我显然想以希望而不是绝望来结束这一集。总之，这将是一个重磅话题。话虽如此，希望你已经准备好了。让我们进入
to the psychology of Skinny Talk. So if you are coming into this completely blind and have no idea what Skinny Talk is, it's basically a set of viral trends on social media platforms that promote extremely thin body ideals, promotes rapid weight loss tactics, a lot of what I eat in a day videos with like enough calories for a literal child, the glorification of extreme thinness. not for body positivity sake or for health and fitness sake, but for aesthetic sake. Skinny Talk essentially began as a hashtag that people could use to bookmark their content as being
“Skinny Talk”的心理学。因此，如果你完全一无所知地进入这个领域，根本不知道什么是“Skinny Talk”，它基本上是社交媒体平台上的一系列病毒式趋势，推广极端的苗条身材标准，推崇快速减重策略，其中有很多诸如“我一天吃什么”的视频，其热量对一个真正的儿童来说都够了，对极端苗条的崇拜不是为了身体积极性，也不是为了健康和健身，而是为了美学。Skinny Talk本质上最初是一个标签，人们可以用它来给自己的内容打上标签，表明其
aligned with extreme weight loss or extreme dieting. But as with any trend, at some stage, it kind of broke free from its corner of the internet and began to become mainstream and popularized, not because of how often this hashtag was being used. That is obviously one component of it, but because of how dramatic and shocking some of these videos were. Visible rib cages, visible hip bones, visible collar bones, thigh gaps, extreme weight loss transformations that honestly could only make you just like gawk in shock and just be like, wow. Like, I can't believe people look like this without kind of asking you to go looking for these videos.
与极端减重或极端节食相符。但和任何趋势一样，在某个阶段，它有点脱离了互联网的角落，开始变得主流和普及，这倒不是因为这个标签被使用的频率——那显然是其中一个组成部分，而是因为其中一些视频是多么戏剧化和令人震惊。清晰可见的肋骨、突出的髋骨、凸显的锁骨、大腿缝、极端的减重蜕变，说实话，只能让你瞠目结舌，忍不住说：“哇。”就像，我不敢相信有人会长成这样，而这甚至不需要你去主动搜索这些视频。
Some of the examples of videos like this that I've seen are, you know, a Russian model eating 500 calories a day because she wants to feel controlled and lean. Five foot eight women who, you know, on her video says, I weigh 42 kilos and the caption is peak feminine physique. videos of very tiny women with the caption, being skinny as an outfit. Another video that like comes to mind was a girl saying, you need a treat. What are you a dog? Exactly. Like go drink your green tea, babe. The shock value of these videos is really what caused this trend to go viral.
我看到过的一些这类视频的例子，比如，一个俄罗斯模特一天只吃500卡路里，因为她想感到受控和精瘦。一个身高5英尺8英寸的女性，在视频中说：“我体重42公斤，”配文是“女性体态的巅峰”。非常娇小的女性的视频，配文是“瘦是一种穿搭”。另一个浮现在脑海的视频是一个女孩说：“你需要一份甜点。你是狗吗？没错。去喝你的绿茶吧，宝贝。”这些视频的冲击力，正是导致这一趋势病毒式传播的原因。
Psychologically, we know this. When we see something that is novel, that is shocking, that is so counter to the norm of what we expect, I guess, human bodies even to look like, or so morally outrageous in some cases, like, you know, telling people that if they want a sweet treat, they're as good as a dog. Like, we respond. We can't help ourselves. And our response is what rewards this content through engagement. Therefore, training the algorithm to show this to more people and training people to produce more of this content.
从心理学上讲，我们深知这一点。当我们看到新奇的、令人震惊的、如此违背我们对人类身体期待的规范（甚至在某些情况下在道德上令人发指）的事物时，比如告诉人们如果他们想吃甜食，他们就和狗差不多。我们会作出反应。我们控制不住自己。而我们的反应正是通过互动来奖励这种内容，从而训练算法将这些内容展示给更多人，并训练人们制作更多此类内容。
I really want to be incredibly clear here. it's not just that these people are thin. Thin people obviously exist in the world and like I really can't think of anything wrong with that. It's that they are promoting this unnatural thinness on their physique that they have obviously obtained through extreme restriction as an ideal that if you do not achieve, it's because it says something about your character. And they're also doing it in a way. that is meant to be shocking and that is meant to be a form of engagement or entertainment.
我在这里真的想表达得非常清楚：这不仅仅是因为这些人很瘦。世界上显然存在瘦人，而且说实话，我觉得这没什么不对的。问题在于，他们将这种通过极端节食明显获得的、不自然的苗条身材作为一种理想标准进行宣传，如果你没有达到这个标准，就说明你的性格有问题。而且他们这样做的方式，旨在制造震惊效果，并将其作为一种互动或娱乐形式。
I saw an article by the National Alliance for Eating Disorders based in the US that said before the skinny talk hashtag was banned in June this year, it had over half a million posts associated with it. And we know just because a hashtag disappears doesn't mean the content hasn't already had a cultural impact. And it also doesn't mean that people aren't. making it. Like the content, this kind of content is kind of like a virus. It just evolves and it begins to conceal itself behind new masks and new hashtags, you know, healthy lifestyle hashtags, nutrition hashtags, model diet hashtags. What's so insidious is that it's not always possible to
我看到美国国家饮食失调联盟（National Alliance for Eating Disorders）发表的一篇文章称，“Skinny Talk”标签在今年6月被禁之前，与其相关的帖子超过了五十万条。我们知道，标签消失并不意味着内容没有产生文化影响。这也并不意味着人们没有在制作它。这类内容就像病毒一样。它只是在不断进化，开始将自己伪装在新的面具和新的标签背后，比如健康生活方式标签、营养标签、模特饮食标签。最阴险的是，你并不总是能够
tell whether a piece of content is just somebody sharing their life, sharing fitzpiration, sharing the natural way their body is, or leaning into this deeply, the deeply dangerous parts of diet culture and the glorification of extreme thinness. There are a few key giveaways, though. The first way to identify if a piece of content is Skinny Talk is the body checking. Body checking refers to the repeated habit of visually or physically, basically like inspecting your body and inspecting your form. either in the mirror, in clothes, in photographs, or in videos. And it's a form of seeking reassurance and
分辨出某段内容究竟只是某人在分享生活、分享健身灵感（fitspiration）、展示他们身体的自然状态，还是陷入了饮食文化中极度危险的部分以及对极端苗条的崇拜。不过，有一些关键的蛛丝马迹。识别某段内容是否属于“Skinny Talk”的第一个方法是“身材检查”（body checking）。身材检查指的是重复习惯于视觉上或物理上、基本上是检查你的身体和体型
seeking validation. The focus in skinny talk content is always on the body, how it looks, which bones are visible, the size of one's waist in comparison to everyday objects, the exaggeration of how thin somebody is. The extreme thinness of one's body is the entertainment. And a 2024 study researchers from here in Australia basically conducted this massive search on TikTok and looked at over 250 videos from the five most popular diet-related hashtags. They found that 50% of these videos involved elements of body checking. It involved elements of the creator repeatedly checking and hyperfixating on their own body, either in the mirror or on video or on their phone.
无论是在镜子里、穿衣服时、照片中还是视频中。这是一种寻求安心和
So body checking is the biggest one. The second biggest giveaway is how food is talked about. Firstly, in these videos, food is often assigned a numerical value or label, often how many calories it has. And normally this numerical value determines the food's moral label, foods being described as good or bad, clean. or junk, safe or dangerous, nice or naughty. This moral label then seems to describe the morality of the person who is consuming it. You know, if they ate the bad food with more calories, they are bad.
寻求认可的形式。Skinny Talk内容中的焦点始终停留在身体上：它看起来如何，哪些骨头清晰可见，与日常用品相比腰部的尺寸，对某人有多瘦的夸张描述。一个人身体的极端苗条就是娱乐本身。澳大利亚的研究人员在2024年对TikTok进行了海量搜索，研究了五个最受欢迎的减肥相关标签中的250多个视频。他们发现，其中50%的视频涉及身材检查的元素。这包含了创作者在镜子、视频或手机中反复检查并过度关注自己身体的元素。
They were bad that day. If they ate the good food with less calories, they were good that day. All of this is seemingly determined by a number attached to a piece of food. And, you know, the food doesn't care. Like the food is just here to give you energy and to give you nutrition. It doesn't, it isn't, isn't a moral thing. Like a food is objectively not bad. It is just a food. It's not a sentient, like, adamant thing. It just exists. But the role of food on Skinny Talk is something to be controlled and something to be policed and something to be moralized. And that's why it has just as much of a focus as like the human body and the thinness. The third giveaway is kind of linked to both of these things.
所以身材检查是最主要的特征。第二个最明显的迹象是人们如何谈论食物。首先，在这些视频中，食物通常被赋予一个数字或标签，通常是它含有多少卡路里。通常这个数字决定了食物的道德标签，食物被描述为好的或坏的、干净的或垃圾的、安全的或危险的、美味的或罪恶的。这种道德标签随后似乎描述了消费它的那个人的道德品质。你知道，如果他们吃了含有更多卡路里的坏食物，他们就是坏的
It's an extension of this idea that food has morality and it's the idea that how you look determines your morality and your value. Often there is a specific twist within all of this content. The thin body is celebrated not just for being thin because like I said, some people just naturally are, but for being controlled, for being clean, for being disciplined. This is what signifies that this person is better than the viewer, because they have something that you could never have. They have the willpower to look the way they do, which is honestly a ridiculous use of willpower. Like, if you have that much willpower, maybe you should use that for something
他们那天就很坏。如果他们吃了热量较少的好食物，他们那天就很好。这一切似乎都是由贴在食物上的数字决定的。而且，你知道，食物根本不在乎。食物来到这里只是为了给你提供能量和营养。它不是、也不是一件道德的事。比如，食物客观上绝不可能是坏的。它只是一种食物。它不是一个有意识的、固执的东西。它只是存在着。但食物在Skinny Talk中的角色是需要被控制、被监管和被道德化的东西。这就是为什么它受到的关注度与人体和苗条度不相上下。第三个迹象与这两点都有所关联。
else. But, you know, for them, this willpower is a sign that they're better than you and that they have value and that they are able to dedicate themselves to this, this, I don't know, project of making their body as visually appealing and aesthetic as they can. This is really, I think, the biggest thing that distinguishes general healthy living weight loss content on social media platforms, which honestly I don't really have an issue with from skinny talk. It's the fact that it goes beyond health. It goes beyond loving your body.
这是“食物具有道德性”这一观念的延伸，也是“你的外表决定了你的道德和价值”这一理念的延伸。所有这些内容中通常都有一个独特的转折。苗条的身材受到赞美，不仅因为它瘦——因为正如我所说，有些人天生就瘦——而是因为它受到控制、因为它是干净的、因为它是自律的。这正是这个人比观众优越的象征，因为他们拥有你永远无法拥有的东西。他们有意志力让自己长成现在的样子，说实话，这简直是对意志力的荒谬运用。如果你有那么多意志力，也许你应该把它用在别的事情上
It goes beyond trying to do the right thing by your body and into making your body a moral and visual symbol for your perceived value as an individual, even if the body actually suffers. Your body, your hunger is something to be suppressed, restricted, disciplined, not listen to. I think this trend really speaks to a cultural mood of if you can just manage your body, you wouldn't have any problems, rather than what systems created body dissatisfaction in the first place, what is actually creating problems with our health, with self-worth, with self-appraisal. This is why Skinny Talk is highly conservative.
但在他们看来，这种意志力是他们比你优秀、他们有价值、并且他们能够全身心投入到这个——我不知道——让自己的身体尽可能在视觉上吸引人、符合美学的工程中的标志。这真的是我认为将社交媒体平台上一般的健康生活减重内容（说实话，我对这本身没什么意见）与“Skinny Talk”区分开来的最大区别。那就是它超越了健康。它超越了爱自己的身体。
in the sense that it preserves ideals rather than dismantling them. You may have seen this argument being raised online, but, you know, the essential idea is that Skinny Talk isn't just diet content, it's not just fitness motivation, it's quite political. The messaging pushed through this kind of content actually mirrors the rise in conservative ideas around gender, around our bodies, around individual responsibility. There was a really interesting article published in April by Lois Sharing, and she explores how far-right groups are increasingly using thinness and body shaming in their recruitment strategies for girls and young women.
它超越了对身体做正确的事情的追求，而是将你的身体变成了一个道德和视觉上的象征，以此来衡量你作为个体的感知价值，即便身体实际上正在遭受痛苦。你的身体、你的饥饿感是需要被压制、限制、管束，而不是去倾听的东西。我认为这种趋势真正反映了一种文化情绪，即“如果你能管好自己的身体，你就不会有任何问题”，而不是去追问究竟是什么系统最初导致了身体不满意，究竟是什么在真正制造着我们健康、自我价值和自我评估方面的问题。这就是为什么“Skinny Talk”高度保守的原因。
Now, that's not through obvious political slogans, it's through aesthetic cues, a kind of soft-focused femininity built on being controlled and disciplined and having restraint and being petite and small and tiny. In this framing, you know, the female body is kind of held up as something quite pure and orderly and morally superior in contrast to what far-right groups, you know, describe the world as, which is chaotic, excessive, undisciplined. Thinness becomes a way to signal belonging,
当然，这并不是通过明显的政治口号，而是通过审美线索，一种建立在被控制、被纪律约束、保持克制、娇小玲珑之上的柔焦女性气质。在这种框架下，你知道，女性的身体被奉为某种相当纯洁、有序和道德上更优越的东西，这与极右翼团体所描述的世界形成了对比，他们所描述的世界是混乱的、无节制的、无纪律的。纤瘦成了一种暗示归属感的方式，
a way to show that you are in control of yourself whilst this world around us, you know, goes crazy. And this matters. You might be thinking this seems a little bit far-fetched. I get it. I think the first time I heard this idea, I was like, that's kind of wild. But it matters because the research does show us that, you know,
一种在周围世界陷入疯狂时向外界证明你能掌控自己的方式。这很重要。你可能会觉得这有点牵强。我懂。我想我第一次听到这个观点时，也觉得这有点离谱。但它之所以重要，是因为研究确实向我们表明，
political beliefs literally shape how you view your own body and how you view others' bodies. as well. One study published in the journal Nature in 2021 actually presented participants with computer-generated body shapes and found that people who identified with more conservative ideologies tended to view thinner bodies as more competent, more responsible, more morally virtuous. Those exact same bodies were perceived differently depending on the viewer's ideology, people who were more liberal or left-leaning, you know, kind of didn't really care and didn't really have a preference either way.
政治信仰确实塑造了你如何看待自己的身体以及如何看待他体的身体。2021年发表在《自然》杂志上的一项研究实际上向参与者展示了电脑生成的身体形状，发现认同更保守意识形态的人倾向于认为更瘦的身体更有能力、更负责任、在道德上更高尚。同样的身体，根据观者的意识形态，会有不同的看法；而那些更自由派或左倾的人，你知道，其实并不太在意，也没有什么偏好。
Another research paper looking at the link between body ideals and conservative or authoritarian ideologies also demonstrated this. Researchers at the University of Bristol and the University of York looked at a representative nationwide sample of 2,000 people, and they captured their answers to this thing called the British social attitude survey to kind of see what is the link between political ideology and how people talk about weight, how they view weight, how they view size. What they found was that weight stigmatizing attitudes were more commonly associated with people who had extreme right-wing authoritarian values. People who had these values were also significantly
另一篇探讨身体理想与保守或威权意识形态之间联系的研究论文也证明了这一点。布里斯托尔大学和约克大学的研究人员调查了一个由2,000人组成的全国代表性样本，他们收集了这些人对所谓的“英国社会态度调查”的回答，以此来观察政治意识形态与人们如何谈论体重、如何看待体重、如何看待体型之间存在什么联系。他们发现，带有体重污名化态度的群体更常见于那些具有极端右翼威权价值观的人。持有这些价值观的人也明显
more likely to believe that larger bodies reflected moral failure. Now, again, this is not to say that every creator making a What I Eat in a Day video is aligned with the far right. It's also not to say that everybody who is naturally thin thinks that they are morally superior. It's just, like, don't take this out of context. It's just really interesting research to just see how trends connect with political attitudes of the time and those trends deeply impact how we see our bodies and how we see ourselves. The underlying narrative to this whole culture is smaller is better, being controlled is virtuous,
更有可能认为较大的体型反映了道德上的失败。再次声明，这并不是说每一个制作“我的一天吃什么”视频的创作者都与极右翼结盟。这也不是说每一个天生苗条的人都认为自己在道德上更优越。这只是——别断章取义。这只是一项非常有趣的研究，展示了潮流如何与当时的政治态度联系在一起，而这些潮流深深地影响着我们如何看待自己的身体和我们自己。贯穿这种文化的底层叙事是：越小越好，被控制是美德，
and your worth is visible in how little space you take up. Okay, with that in mind, we are going to take a short break. When we return, let's discuss a few other explanations for why Skinny Talk has managed to capture so much of our attention and some of the consequences of this prevailing back trend towards extreme unhealthy thinness. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past
你的价值体现在你占用的空间有多小。好了，考虑到这一点，我们要进行短暂的休息。当我们回来时，我们将讨论对“瘦素”（Skinny Talk）为何能吸引如此多关注的其他一些解释，以及这种向极端不健康瘦削回归的流行趋势所带来的一些后果。请继续收听。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透
the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 TWO%。
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
乔治·布什到底跟小金有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会邀请你来到这里，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes.
大谈特谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊可卡因，不过只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black. black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。黑人。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《The Hard Way》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，我们太过于投入到追逐中
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且我们不知道什么时候才算够，因为人们总是盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于赢与输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《The Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷g，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，新闻报道，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻
Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so we can't talk about Skinny Talk without talking about the rise of weight loss drugs because it seems that they have really been increasing in parallel. To be honest, I'll make it super clear. I really have no judgment on whether you choose to use weight loss drugs or not. I have friends who do, I've seen it change their life. I also know as someone who has never been small, who will never be small because I'm
马里科帕县报道，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 IHeart 广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。好了，所以我们在谈论瘦身话题时，不能不谈论减肥药的兴起，因为它们似乎真的是在并行增长。老实说，我把话说得很清楚。对于你是否选择使用减肥药，我真的没有任何评判。我有朋友在使用，我见过它改变了他们的生活。我也知道，作为一个从来没有瘦过、也永远不会瘦的人，因为我
5'8 with broad shoulders and the child of literal athletes, that when you are bigger, whatever you do is scrutinized, right? You choose to take weight loss drugs. You are shamed. You choose to accept your body. You are also shamed. You choose to do it naturally or lose weight. Also shamed. Like, there is always these two sides that, like, either want you to drastically change who you are or want you to stay exactly in the form that you are. And you're going to receive pressure from each, whichever decision you choose. I was listening to an episode of maintenance phase where the host, Aubrey Gordon, said something along the lines of when you're fat, people are obsessed with your health like it's something that is their business or it's something that is impacting them. And I think you can't escape it.
身高 5'8 英尺，拥有宽阔的肩膀，而且是名副其实的运动员的孩子，当你身材更魁梧时，无论你做什么都会受到仔细审视，对吧？你选择服用减肥药。你会被羞辱。你选择接纳自己的身体。你也会被羞辱。你选择用自然的方法或减肥。同样会被羞辱。就像，总是存在这两种立场，要么希望你彻底改变自己，要么希望你保持目前的形态。无论你做出什么决定，你都会承受来自两方面的压力。我当时在听一期《Maintenance Phase》节目，主持人奥布里·戈登说了一句类似这样的话：当你胖的时候，人们对你的健康着想就像那是他们自己的事一样，或者像是对他们有影响的事一样。我想你根本无法逃避这一点。
Now, the thing is, is that weight loss drugs also have health consequences. But again, if you're overweight and you're taking it, you know, your health is not anybody else's business but your own. It's your personal choice, how you want to relate and treat your body is up to you. Kind of the same with Skinny Talk, right? These people making these videos, if that's the approach you want to have to your body, like that's up to you as harmful or unharmful as you think it is. But when it comes to either of those things, you can't ignore how that choice has come about. Has it come from a desire to be healthy or a desire for aesthetics?
现在的问题是，减肥药也会带来健康后果。但话说回来，如果你超重并正在服用它，你知道，你的健康除了你本人之外，不关任何人的事。这是你的个人选择，你如何看待和对待自己的身体取决于你。这有点类似于瘦身话题，对吧？这些制作视频的人，如果这就是你对待身体的方式，那这取决于你，无论你认为它是危害还是无害。但说到这两者中的任何一个，你都无法忽视这种选择是如何产生的。它是出于对健康的渴望还是对审美的渴望？
and can we say that the same intention is what everybody has? You know, the thing is, OZempic, like, does change people's lives and is really important for certain medical conditions and people who are really struggling to regulate their appetite and their weight and, you know, if they have type type 2 diabetes, that's, that aspect of it as well. However, I think now it's become something more than medical. It's become a trend. And some of the skinny talk content we see about how life is just better when you're skinny
我们能否说每个人都有着相同的意图？你知道，事实是，Ozempic确实改变了人们的生活，对于某些医疗状况以及那些真正难以调节食欲和体重的人来说，这非常重要，你知道，如果他们有2型糖尿病，这也是其中的一个方面。然而，我认为现在它已经变得不仅仅是医疗了。它已经成为了一种潮流。我们看到的一些关于“变瘦生活才更美好”的瘦身内容，
and tiny, how being thin is the outfit, is people who readily say like, OZempic got me this body. And that acts as not just a form of honesty in sharing, but as an advertisement, a subliminal advertisement that this is who I am now, this is admirable, this is a, respectable physical physique. Here's how I got it. And I'm not going to tell you. Obviously, they can't tell you if it's right for you.
关于纤瘦就是时尚本身，是那些欣然宣称“是 Ozempic 给了我这个身材”的人。这不仅是一种分享时的诚实表现，更是一种广告，一种潜意识里的广告，即这就是现在的我，这是令人钦佩的，这是一个受人尊敬的体格。这就是我得到它的方式。而且我不会告诉你。很显然，他们无法告诉你这是否适合你。
But of course people are going to see that and think that kind of transformation is something that would make me happier. Here's the thing. When these medications enter the culture of aesthetics and just enter the culture in general, they carry messages. Some of those messages are helpful for people who truly need them. but many are harmful when they slip into the aesthetic or marketing sphere because this drug is at the end of the day. You know, the pharmaceutical industry doesn't create drugs to help people and to change lives.
但人们看到这一点，当然会认为这种转变是能让我更快乐的事情。问题就在这里。当这些药物进入审美文化并普遍进入文化时，它们传达了信息。其中一些信息对真正需要它们的人是有帮助的，但当它们溜进审美或营销领域时，许多信息是有害的，因为归根结底这种药物。你知道，制药行业生产药物并不是为了帮助人们和改变生活。
That's obviously what they say they're doing, but if there was no market for them, there's no way they would do it. They are making these drugs to make money and therefore they are marketing them to make money, regardless of who might be hurt by that decision. They want as many customers as possible, and as a result, it can amplify the logic of things like Skinny Talk, that if you are thin, you are valued. And here is an easy way that doesn't really include health as a central part of the conversation, but as a secondary thought, that you can achieve this. Thinness still prevails as this.
这显然是他们所宣称的，但如果没有市场，他们绝对不会这么做。他们制造这些药物是为了赚钱，因此他们营销这些药物也是为了赚钱，而不管谁可能会因为这个决定而受到伤害。他们想要尽可能多的客户，结果，这可能会放大瘦身话题之类的逻辑，即如果你很瘦，你就是有价值的。这里有一个简单的方法，它并没有真正把健康作为对话的核心部分，而是作为一个次要的想法，你可以通过它来实现这一点。纤瘦依然占据主导地位，成为了
goal that we all need to achieve. And now with the use of these weight loss drugs, you know, that culture is being accelerated at a level that is really dangerously driving demand. Now, obviously, it would be great to say that weight loss drugs are only being used by people that need them or for reasons unrelated to physical appearance. And even if they are being used for physical appearance, you know, for people who, you know, again, are seriously at a point where they don't feel healthy about themselves. that's just simply not the case. I saw a video of someone the other day who was like, I want to lose,
我们所有人都需要实现的目标。现在随着这些减肥药的使用，你知道，这种文化正在以一种真正危险地推动需求的速度加速。现在，很显然，如果能说减肥药只被需要它们的人使用，或者用于与外表无关的原因，那就太棒了。即使它们被用于外表，你知道，对于那些，你知道，再次强调，真的处于对自己感觉不健康的边缘的人来说，事实根本并非如此。我前几天看到一个视频，里面的人说我想减掉，
I don't want to be too specific, but she was like, I want to lose a certain amount of weight by Christmas, and I'm thinking about going on a Zempic to do that. And she weighed 65 kilos. And I was like, that just seems so bizarre that you would risk your health to take a medication that it seems like, from my perspective, your body doesn't really need. And the risk is, is that when we tie our worth to what it says on the scale
我不想说得太具体，但她说她想在圣诞节前减掉一定数量的体重，她正在考虑使用 Ozempic 来做到这一点。而她当时体重 65 公斤。当时我觉得这太不可思议了，为了服用一种从我的角度来看你的身体根本不需要的药物，你竟然去冒健康风险。风险在于，当我们把我们的价值与体重秤上的数字联系在一起时
or how we look, you will do drastic things, like go on a serious medication to maintain or to gain the physique of the moment and to match the shape and the body form that is currently in circulation. I feel like every one of us has had that moment where we're just,
或者与我们的外表联系在一起，你就会做出极端的事情，比如服用严肃的药物来维持或获得当下的体格，并迎合目前正在流行的身材和体型。我觉得我们每个人都有过那种时刻，当时我们就在想，
like beauty standards are so exhausting. Like every two to three years, our bodies are expected to change, to stay in line with what is expected of the human physique and what is beautiful. It's like we're a piece of clay. One year we need to take off a piece the next year we need to put it back on. Then we need to squeeze these bits in and the next year expand these bits back out. Thinness has been in and out of trend for over 100 years. and this hurts every body type, whether you're naturally thin or not, whether you're naturally
审美标准太让人精疲力竭了。就像每两到三年，我们的身体就被期望发生改变，以符合人类体格的预期以及什么是美的标准。感觉我们就像是一块粘土。今年我们需要削掉一块，明年我们需要把它粘回去。然后我们需要把这些部位挤压进去，第二年再把这些部位扩展开来。纤瘦潮流已经流行和过时了一百多年了，这伤害了每一种体型，无论你天生苗条与否，无论你天生
curvy or not, because when one is in, the other one has to be out. When thinness is in, the curvy girls are made to feel terrible. When the curves are in, if you're thin, you know, now it's your turn to hate yourself for a couple of years or drastically change your body to be back into what is hot and what is fit and what is trending. You know, in the 1920s, we had the women's like kind of flapper fashion, which was built around thinness and boyish figures in the 1960s. We saw a resurgence of that when models like Twiggy were, you know, they were tiny, they were adored. Then we had the 1990s where like heroin chic was like really the trend, coffee, cocaine, cigarettes. Like that's the goal that everybody aspired to. But in
曲线优美与否，因为当一种身材流行时，另一种身材就必须靠边站。当纤瘦流行时，曲线美的女孩会觉得自己糟糕透顶。当曲线美流行时，如果你很瘦，你知道，现在轮到你因为讨厌自己几年而痛苦了，或者彻底改变你的身体，以便重新回到什么是辣的、什么是健康的、什么是流行之中。你知道，在20世纪20年代，我们有女性的“flapper”时尚，这种时尚是围绕着纤瘦和男孩般的体型建立的；在20世纪60年代，我们看到了这种风格的卷土重来，当时像崔姬（Twiggy）这样的模特，你知道，她们娇小玲珑，备受崇拜。然后我们在20世纪90年代经历了“海洛因时尚”（heroin chic）真正成为潮流的时期，咖啡、可卡因、香烟。就像那是每个人都渴望的目标。但在
Between that, we also had moments where having a BBL or being really curvy or very voluptuous was also the ideal and was what was admired. It just constantly changes back and forth. And nowadays, it changes even more rapidly because it changes according to the algorithm, which basically replaces itself every two months. Instead of like one particular magazine cover or particular model, like setting the tone. Like we scroll past hundreds of bodies an hour. Alpha UPage learns what we hover over, what we rewatch, what we feel an emotional response to. The ideal becomes not just aspirational, but this like echo chamber of this is normal because this is all I'm seeing online. And because trends change because Skinny Talk won't be the final trend just like getting a BBL wasn't either.
在此之外，我们也有过这样的时期：拥有巴西丰臀术（BBL）、身材极度曲线玲珑或非常丰满也是一种理想，是受人赞赏的。这种审美一直在来回变化。而如今，它的变化甚至更加迅速，因为它是根据算法在改变，算法基本上每两个月就会自我更新一次。不再是由某一本特定的杂志封面或某一个特定的模特来引领风潮。我们每小时会刷过几百个身体。算法会了解我们悬停在哪里、我们重播了什么、我们对什么产生情感共鸣。理想身材不仅变成了令人向往的目标，还变成了一个回音室：这很正常，因为这就是我在网上看到的一切。而且因为潮流在不断改变，因为“白瘦幼言论”不会是最终的潮流，就像做 BBL 手术也不是一样。
What happens then? What happens when, for example, you have gotten on a drug like OZempic that you'll never be able to stop taking a drug that can destroy your digestive system? What happens when next year the new ideal body emerges and it's something that you can't achieve? It's just always going to keep you on your feet. This is where the concept of effective forecasting comes in. The idea that once I look like that, then I'll be confident. Once I weigh less than X kilos, then I'll be happy and doing anything you can to get there. Studies show the opposite.
那接下来会发生什么？比方说，当你开始使用像 Ozempic 这样的药物，而你永远无法停药，这种药物甚至会摧毁你的消化系统，那时会发生什么？当明年新的理想身材出现，而那是你无法企及的时候，会发生什么？它只会一直让你悬心吊胆。这就是“效能预测”这一概念发挥作用的地方。这种想法是：一旦我看起来那样，我就会有自信；一旦我体重低于 X 公斤，我就会快乐，为此你会不惜一切代价去达成目标。然而研究表明，事实恰恰相反。
Body dissatisfaction tends to stay the same or even increase once you achieve your ideal body. because the goal post always moves. It's always going to be one inch away from where you are now. It's why suddenly, like, having really toned abs and arms is like the new thing because now that skinny is achievable for anybody if they want to get on these weight loss drugs, what's the next thing for Zique that people can gatekeep? because the beauty ideal can't be everybody, otherwise there's nothing to sell us. With that in mind, let's talk about the damage and impact of Skinny Talk,
一旦你达到了理想身材，对身体的不满往往会保持不变，甚至还会增加。因为目标总是在移动。它总是离你现在的状态只有一英寸之遥。这就是为什么突然之间，拥有紧致的腹肌和手臂成了新潮流；因为既然任何人只要想用这些减肥药就能达到骨感，那么对于那些热衷于制造门槛的人来说，下一个用来拿捏大众的“智商税”或门槛又是什么？因为美得标准不能属于所有人，否则就没有东西卖给我们了。带着这个想法，让我们来谈谈“白瘦幼言论”造成的伤害和影响，
starting with the obvious one, arise in eating disorders. In the past decade, rates of anorexia and bulimia have almost doubled. One 2025 study actually suggested that the biggest spike in these rates, obviously accounting for population growth has occurred in the last two years. Let me be very clear. Anorexia in particular is the most dangerous mental disorder in the world. It is the most deadly, the most expensive to treat, it has the highest rate of relapse, and it does significant long-term damage to our bodies that they might never recover from.
从最显而易见的一个开始：进食障碍的激增。在过去十年中，厌食症和贪食症的发病率几乎翻了一番。一项 2025 年的研究甚至表明，剔除人口增长的因素后，这些发病率的最大激增实际上发生在过去的两年里。我要明确指出，厌食症尤其是世界上最危险的精神疾病。它是致死率最高的、治疗费用最高的、复发率最高的，并且它会对我们的身体造成严重且长期的损害，可能永远无法恢复。
imagine every day entering a space and someone at the door tells you, hey, there's a chance you could develop a life-altering deadly illness if you walk through that door today. Do you still go in? Would you do it? That's what it's like going on TikTok and Instagram at the moment, especially if you're young, especially if you're a teenager. And if you think that's dramatic linking social media usage and the development of an eating disorder, I want to tell you about a 2020 review that looked at 50 studies across 17 countries
想象一下，每天进入一个空间，门口有人告诉你：“嘿，如果你今天走进那扇门，你可能会患上一种改变人生、致命的疾病。”你还会进去吗？你会这么做吗？这就像此刻刷 TikTok 和 Instagram 的感觉一样，尤其是如果你很年轻，特别是如果你还是个青少年。如果你觉得把社交媒体的使用与进食障碍的发展联系起来是小题大做，我想告诉你一项 2020 年的综述研究，它调查了 17 个国家的 50 项研究，
with over 10,000 participants. That concluded, one of the most plausible and significant risk factors for the development of an eating disorder is social media usage. Specifically, exposure to thin or fit ideals, exposure to appearance-based content, and social media trends. relating to dieting, body composition, and fitness. One of the conceptual models that this study proposes is actually what we call a self-perpetuating cycle of risk where social media use increases body image concerns, which increases disordered eating, further feeding into social media use and comparison. Like these trends, like I cannot express.
涵盖了超过 10,000 名参与者。该研究得出结论：进食障碍发展最合理且显著的风险因素之一就是使用社交媒体。具体而言，是接触骨感或健身理想、接触基于外表的内容，以及与节食、身体成分和健身相关的社交媒体潮流。该研究提出的其中一个概念模型，实际上就是我们所说的“风险自我恶化循环”：社交媒体的使用加剧了身材焦虑，进而增加了失调性进食，这又进一步助长了社交媒体的使用和攀比。就像这些潮流一样，我简直无法表达。
They literally ruin people's lives. They ruin their lives and their health for years to come. Being 20 kilos, 10 kilos overweight is nothing compared to being extremely thin and dieting and restricting your body of nutrition, especially during formative years of your life. And we know that these trends touch everybody. Their emotional grip is. in the minds of anybody who has ever felt pressure to meet a beauty standard or an attractiveness standard. But for girls in particular, young girls and women, the background noise is pretty intense.
它们真的毁了人们的生活。它们毁了人们的生活和未来几年的健康。与极度消瘦、节食以及在身体发育关键时期剥夺身体营养相比，超重 20 公斤或 10 公斤根本不算什么。而且我们知道，这些潮流影响着每一个人。它们的情感控制力渗透到了每一个曾感受到压力去迎合某种美学或吸引力标准的人的心中。但尤其是对女孩、年轻女孩和女性而言，这种背景噪音相当强烈。
I think female bodies have always kind of been sites of public commentary. Our bodies are evaluated before we can even speak. We learn very young that bodies are not just ours. Like they are things that will be looked at and judged. approved, dismissed, compared, what we weigh, how we look, how much space we take up, all of it becomes a kind of social currency. It becomes a way to keep us in check, and we understand that. I couldn't tell you the amount of times a man has disagreed with me on the internet
我认为女性的身体在某种程度上一直是公众评头论足的场所。我们的身体在我们甚至还不会说话之前就已经被评判了。我们很小就懂得了，身体不只是我们自己的。它们是会被审视、被评判、被认可、被否定、被比较的东西，我们的体重、我们的外表、我们占用了多少空间，这一切都变成了一种社会货币。它成了控制我们的一种方式，而我们对此心知肚明。我数不清有多少次，互联网上的某个男性不同意我的观点，
or come across something about my content he doesn't like, and his first reaction is to call me fat, because he knows that is a way to put me in my place. You know, I ran a half marathon this year. I exercise every single day. I honestly love my body after years of not and it still bothers me because it's such a cultural means of control to comment on a woman's body to make her feel bad enough that she will shut up. There's research showing that girls internalized body surveillance, the sense of like watching themselves and being watched much more intensely and much more
或者看到了关于我的内容中他不喜欢的部分，他的第一反应就是骂我胖，因为他知道这是让我守规矩的一种方式。你知道的，我今年跑了半程马拉松。我每天都在锻炼。在经历了多年的挣扎后，我真心爱上了自己的身体，但这仍然让我困扰，因为对女性身体评头论足是一种根深蒂固的文化控制手段，其目的就是让她感到足够糟糕，从而乖乖闭嘴。研究表明，女孩内化的身体监视——那种比男孩更强烈、更早地审视自己和被审视的感觉——要严重得多，
early on than boys. And this is what is known as self-objectification. When you start living in your body as something that is seen rather than something that you feel. Over time, it feels like your body is a project, a visual project, a moral project for others to critique. It is something to manage rather than nourish and really appreciate. And when we look at how body image develops, we see this pattern over and over again. Girls who feel watched, learn to watch themselves. girls who are praised for being small, learn to shrink.
发生的时间也更早。这就是所谓的自我客体化。当你开始把自己的身体当成一个被观看的对象，而不是一种去感受的实体时。久而久之，你会觉得自己的身体是一个项目：一个视觉项目，一个供他人批判的道德项目。它是一个需要管理而不是去滋养和由衷欣赏的东西。当我们观察身材焦虑是如何发展的时候，我们一次又一次地看到了这种模式：感到被审视的女孩学会了审视自己，因身材娇小而受到表扬的女孩学会了缩小自己，
Girls who see women apologizing for eating cake, they learn to apologize for hunger. So you see how these trends literally shape the psychology of people witnessing them. There's another disorder we have to talk about here as well. I'm sure you've already expected me to talk about it. It's orthorexia nervosa. Orthorexia is basically described as a fixation on healthy eating to the point where it becomes unhealthy. It's this familiar pattern of eating only strictly clean foods, moralizing food categories into good and bad,
看到女性为吃蛋糕而道歉的女孩，学会了为饥饿感到抱歉。所以你看，这些潮流是如何切实地塑造了目睹它们的那些人的心理的。这里我们还必须讨论另一种疾病。我确信你们已经料到我会谈论它了。那就是神经性进食狂热（健康强迫症 / 极端的健康饮食强迫症）。“健康强迫症”基本上被描述为对健康饮食的执着，达到了不健康的程度。这种熟悉的模式包括：只吃严格意义上的纯净食物，将食物类别进行道德化分类，划分为好的和坏的，
excluding entire food groups like your body doesn't need those things, tracking calories, tracking macros rigidly, overall just letting food control your life by trying to control it, but behind the mask of this is healthy. It's so hard to draw the line between caring about nutrition and food because you do care about your health and because objectively some foods are better for your body and caring about it because this is just another form of psychological control or maladaptive coping. I can't control my life. I can't control my past.
排除掉整个食物类别——就好像你的身体不需要那些东西一样，死板地追踪卡路里、追踪宏量营养素，总而言之，就是试图通过控制食物来让食物控制你的生活，然而其面具背后却是“这很健康”。要在关心营养和食物（因为你确实关心健康，且客观上某些食物对身体更好）与因为这只是心理控制或适应不良的应对机制而关心食物之间划清界限，是极其困难的。我无法控制我的生活，我无法控制我的过去，
I can't control the future. I can control what I eat. thinking about food obsessively is not normal unless maybe you have severe allergies or intolerances or you are literally starving. You know, especially if you're in your 20s and you're healthy and you're feeling good and you're functioning at the level that you want. There's no need to be like extreme dieting. You know, there's a huge distinction between making healthy choices, being conscious of your diet and a rigorous all-consuming obsession with food and bad foods that is about really underneath it all restriction and control.
我无法控制未来，但我可以控制我吃什么。强迫性地思考食物是不正常的，除非你可能患有严重的过敏、不耐受，或者你真的在挨饿。你知道的，特别是如果你正值二十多岁，身体健康，感觉良好，并且以你想要的状态运转，根本没有必要进行极端节食。你知道，做出健康选择、对饮食保持清醒的意识，与对食物以及“垃圾食品”产生一种严苛的、消耗一切的痴迷之间，存在着巨大的区别；而这种痴迷的底层逻辑其实就是限制与控制。
The real question to ask is if you see these videos of people talking about healthy eating, if you see these videos of people talking about calories and macros, is this decision costing them more life than it's giving them? Like that is a real way to identify when something is distorted. because for some of them it's just not, that's not disordered eating. If it is costing their life more than it is giving their life, that's disordered. When I was in my late teens, the amount I thought about food because I was going through something similar to this, like made my whole world so much smaller.
真正要问的问题是：当你看到这些人们谈论健康饮食的视频时，当你看到这些人们谈论卡路里和宏量营养素的视频时，这个决定带给他们的生活是更多，还是消耗了他们更多的生命？这确实是识别某种事物是否扭曲的方法。因为对其中一些人来说，这根本算不上失调性进食。如果它消耗了他们生活中的生命，多于它带给生活的，那就是失调。当我处于青春期晚期时，我满脑子都在想食物，因为我正在经历类似的事情，这让我的整个世界变得无比狭小。
Like I remember going on a trip to New York with my family and just not enjoying it because all I thought about was food. and I couldn't participate because it wasn't healthy. It wasn't aligned with like how many calories I was allowed for that day. All you think about is food all of the time. There is like not much room for anything else. And it's so not only physically unhealthy but like mentally exhausting. Now again, back to Skinny Talk.
就像我记得和家人去纽约旅行，却根本没有好好享受，因为我脑子里想的全都是食物。我无法融入其中，因为它不健康，不符合我那天被允许摄入的卡路里额度。你满脑子、任何时候想的都只有食物。几乎没有空间容纳其他任何东西。这不仅在生理上不健康，而且在心理上极度消耗。现在，我们再次回到“白瘦幼言论”。
We think that Skinny Talk might only be linked to, you know, eating disorders like anorexia. it's actually more linked to orthorexia. A 222 survey carried out in Italy, looked at a sample of 4,000 participants and found that for participants who reported using social media for over 60 minutes a day, the prevalence of orthorexia was significantly higher. We see this as clear as day,
我们以为“白瘦幼言论”可能只跟诸如厌食症之类的进食障碍有关，但实际上它跟健康强迫症的关系更密切。2022 年在意大利开展的一项调查考察了 4,000 名参与者的样本，发现对于报告每天使用社交媒体超过 60 分钟的参与者来说，“健康强迫症”的患病率显著更高。我们对这一点看得清清楚楚，
especially in like the gym community and on like gym TikTok. It's become really normalized to do these like healthy meal swaps. For me, I absolutely hate those like no carb, no sugar, protein powder-filled fixes that like come up as recommendations. You know, I used to eat those. They literally just taste disgusting. And you know what? You can eat what you want. Maybe if you like that, like, go for it. If that's your cup of tea, like I don't have an issue with it. Feed your body what you want and what it wants. It's just that there's an underlying
特别是在健身社群和健身 TikTok 上。做那些“健康代餐”已经变得非常正常化。对我而言，我绝对讨厌那些无碳水、无糖、塞满了蛋白粉的替代品，它们总是作为推荐弹出来。你知道的，我曾经吃过那些东西。它们的味道简直恶心透顶。你知道吗？你想吃什么就吃什么。也许如果你喜欢那种东西，那就去吃吧。如果那是你的菜，我其实没意见。给你的身体你想喂的东西，以及它想要的东西。只是有太多人如果没吃那种健康版本的食物，就会感到一种潜藏的
discomfort and shame so many people feel if they don't eat that healthy version. That restricts them from being able to participate in everyday life. You know, I shouldn't eat that burger. That biscuit is bad to the point where, again, life gets smaller. This isn't just about a trend. This isn't just about a body ideal. This is about the quality of your one true, miraculous, wonderful life that you are, like you are putting joy and happiness on hold to meet a construct that probably wouldn't be real
不适感和羞耻感。这剥夺了他们参与日常生活的能力。你知道的，“我不该吃那个汉堡”、“那个饼干是坏东西”，这种想法会导致——又一次——生活变得越来越狭隘。这不仅仅关乎一种潮流，这不仅仅关乎一种身材理想。这关乎你此生仅有的一次、奇迹般、美好的生命的质量；而你却为了迎合一个很可能并不真实的建构，把快乐和幸福给搁置了——
if you weren't online. Okay. We're going to take another short break here. But when we return, let's talk about what the heck we can do about this and, you know, how we can counteract the skinny talk influence in everyday life. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
如果你不上网的话，这个建构根本就不会存在。好了。我们在这里要进行另一个短暂的休息。但当我们回来时，让我们来谈谈我们究竟能对此做些什么，以及，你知道的，我们如何在日常生活中抵御“白瘦幼言论”的影响。请继续收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我将剖析在 我们这个陌生现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，带大家看穿统治健康产业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》，
That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
就在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不在乎黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of America. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill），大谈 80 年代的快克（可卡因）。坦白说，84 年对我很重要，不只是因为美国的快克。我倒是不介意在某天聊聊快克，不过为了让大家知道我的意思。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆上台面了。
Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
谢谢你帮我把那句话说完。我不认为还有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方订阅收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师，
Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。然而我们还在继续追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
并且我们不知道什么时候才算“够了”。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要，还是你当一个好人只是因为你感到害怕？因为这是两种截然不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now.
这是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正地、纯粹地当一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《迎难而上》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中前后矛盾的明显漏洞。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税钱被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的推进，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm obviously not going to end the episode being like, this all sucks. Good luck out there.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我显然不会以“这一切糟透了，祝你们好运”这样的话来结束这一集。
That's not how we're going to do this. Instead, I want to give you some things to do or some exercises to avoid the influence of Skinny Talk as much as you can. I think honestly, by listening to this, you'll have checked the first. first thing off the list, which is just being more aware of what kind of content you're consuming. Just in general, you know, once you've seen and once you can see the content clearly, you do get to decide how you want to respond to it rather than just letting its tentacles like slither into your mind because the mere exposure effect here is powerful.
这不是我们的风格。相反，我想给你们提供一些做法或练习，以便尽可能地避开“白瘦幼言论”的影响。老实说，我认为通过收听这一期节目，你已经完成了清单上的第一项，那就是更加意识到自己正在消费什么类型的内容。总的来说，你知道的，一旦你看到了这些内容，一旦你能清晰地看清它们，你就可以决定自己想如何回应它，而不是任由它的触手像蛇一样溜进你的大脑，因为这里的单纯曝光效应是非常强大的。
Just repeatedly seeing something, even if you don't think you're engaging with it on a deeper level does have an impact on how you will go on to view your body. You don't need to overhaul your entire life. You don't need to delete TikTok entirely, flee to the woods, become digitally isolated, although I feel like a lot of us kind of want to at this point, but you don't have to. Sometimes the simplest starting point is just recognizing what you're looking at, noticing the tone, noticing the body checking, noticing the rituals of control, noticing how they're romanticizing, and something that is probably unhealthy and just pausing and putting a buffer between you and that content. Just critically analyzing what you have seen.
仅仅是反复看到某样东西，即使你认为自己没有进行更深层次的接触，也会对你日后如何看待自己的身体产生影响。你不需要彻底重塑你的整个生活。你不需要完全删掉 TikTok、逃进树林、与数字世界隔绝，尽管我觉得我们很多人现在都有这种冲动，但你没必要这么做。有时最简单的起点只是识别你正在看的东西，注意它的语调，注意身体检查（body checking），注意控制的仪式，注意到它们是如何将可能不健康的东西浪漫化的，然后暂停一下，在你和那个内容之间设置一个缓冲。批判性地分析你所看到的东西。
And thinking to yourself, you know, how many people do I see who actually look like this? What kind of dark thoughts might this be bringing up for me? Are they going to actually lead me down a better path? is being involved in this content going to make me a better person. This is when you can really use, like, obviously, the tools of TikTok or Instagram to just say not interested. I honestly, the moment I see a piece of content come out for somebody that is very obviously skinny talk aligned, like I just block their account.
并在心里想一想：“我看到的这些人里，到底有多少人实际上长这样？这可能会给我带来什么样的负面想法？它们真的会引导我走向一条更好的道路吗？参与这些内容会让我成为一个更好的人吗？”这时，你就可以真正地利用诸如 TikTok 或 Instagram 的工具，直接点击“不感兴趣”。说实话，当我看到某个人发布的内容明显属于“白瘦幼言论”时，我就会立刻拉黑他们的账号。
I just, I don't want to see it. Like, I just, I don't want to see it. I respect them being able to do what they want with their body. I just don't want it to influence how I see my body. And that really does work to, and I've seen it work, to reshape my algorithm. Like the good thing about the algorithm, good, the good thing about the algorithm is that it is trainable. It's boringly obedient.
我就是不想看。我只是不想看。我尊重他们用自己的身体去做他们想做的事，我只是不希望它影响我如何看待自己的身体。这确实管用，而且我亲眼看到它重塑了我的算法。算法的好处在于——好的一点是，算法是可以被训练的。它无聊而顺从。
So if you stop liking or lingering on those videos, if you quietly unfollow or block creators who make you feel smaller, feel that you need to be smaller in your own life, your feed will change. and when your feed changes, obviously we all spend a lot of time online, your environment changes, your thoughts change, and your habits change. This is what we call rewiring your online environment. It's the same way that you should, you know, that if you were friends with a terrible person
所以，如果你停止点赞或在这些视频上停留，如果你默默地取消关注或拉黑那些让你觉得自己很渺小、让你觉得在现实生活中必须变得更小的创作者，你的信息流就会改变。而当你的信息流改变时——显然我们所有人都花很多时间在网上——你的环境就会改变，你的想法就会改变，你的习惯也会改变。这就是我们所说的“重塑你的网络环境”。这就像你在生活中，
in your life and you cut them out, your life would probably get better. It's the same reason why we say you should wash your bed sheets or you should invest in getting good lighting in your home. Like what's in your environment, the content, the people, the environment you consume. has an impact, make sure you are being cautious with it. I also think when you feel the need to meet the trend, truly ask yourself, are there things my body isn't capable of doing right now, that being thinner is going to help me with? Let's be real. Maybe you don't feel great in your body. Maybe you do feel sluggish. You do think that you could exercise more, show your body more love,
如果你和一个糟糕透顶的人交朋友，然后你跟他断交了，你的生活可能会变得更好一样。这就是为什么我们说你应该洗床单，或者你应该投资为家里买好的照明。你环境中的内容、人们、你所消费的环境，都会产生影响，确保你对此保持谨慎。我也觉得，当你感到需要迎合某种潮流时，真正地问问自己：现在有没有什么事是我的身体做不到、而变得更瘦就能帮我做到的？说实话。也许你对自己的身体感觉不太好。也许你确实觉得无精打采。你确实认为自己可以多锻炼一点，多给身体一些爱，
Is being that level of thin going to fix that? Is drastic weight loss going to help you? Chances are eating 1,200 calories a day or less probably isn't going to be aligned with the healthiest version that you can be. Skinny Talk is one version of somebody's idea of health. Don't let it be the only version. What is your body calling for that is maybe more holistic, more balanced, more sustainable, more right for you? Or does something maybe just actually not need to change at all?
那么达到那种程度的瘦能解决问题吗？急剧的减肥能帮到你吗？很有可能，每天摄入 1200 卡路里或更少，并不符合你能达到的最健康状态。“白瘦幼言论”只是某个人关于健康的看法的一种版本。不要让它成为唯一的版本。你的身体真正呼唤的是什么？它可能更全面、更平衡、更可持续、更适合你？或者说其实根本没有任何东西需要改变？
You know, if you weren't online, if you weren't seeing these videos, would you know naturally organically that anything was wrong with your body? If the answer is no, you don't need to change. It's the same with all kinds of marketing, right? Skinny Talk is trying to convince you that this and this only will change your life, this lip product, this bad, like this new lamp, this diet, it's probably not true. In fact, it's definitely not true. You know, when I was at my smallest, when I lost weight very fast, I was also incapable of running for longer than five minutes. I was always tired. I was mad all the time. I basically didn't talk to my family. The thing is, the marketing for Skinny Talk is so good. It's really good.
你知道的，如果你不上网，如果你看不到这些视频，你会天然地、有机地发现你的身体有什么不对劲吗？如果答案是否定的，你就不需要改变。这跟所有类型的营销都一样，对吧？“白瘦幼言论”正试图让你相信，只有这个、只有这样才能改变你的生活：这款唇膏、这个包、这盏新台灯、这种节食法——这很可能不是真的。事实上，这绝对不是真的。你知道的，当我瘦到人生体重谷底、体重迅速下降的时候，我也同样无法连续跑步超过五分钟。我总是很累。我无时无刻不在生气。我基本上不和家人说话。问题是，“白瘦幼言论”的营销做得太好了。真的太好了。
It's also entirely wrong. The thing that can be most, grounding, truly grounding, is just coming back to your values. Not your goals, not aesthetics, your core values. What matters to you? Who do you want to be? How do you want to feel about yourself? How do you want to experience your finite time on this planet? If your values are peace, presence, connection, joy, ease, ask yourself, does this content or behavior align with who I want to be? Does body checking align with peace? No. Does skipping dinner align with connection?
但它也完全是错的。最能让人脚踏实地、真正让人安心的事情，就是回归你的价值观。不是你的目标，不是美学，而是你的核心价值观。什么对你最重要？你想成为什么样的人？你希望如何看待自己？你希望如何体验你在这个星球上有限的生命？如果你的价值观是平静、活在当下、连接、快乐、松弛，问问自己：这个内容或行为符合我想成为的那个人吗？进行身体检查符合平静吗？不符合。跳过晚餐符合连接吗？
No. Does obsessing over whether my stomach looks flat align with joy? No. And then this is where something called opposite action becomes really helpful. And it is exactly what it says on the tin. Like if your mind tells you that you should check your body again, the opposite action may be to just stay exact. where you are, to breathe, to sit through the urge, to feel the discomfort, rise, peak,
不符合。痴迷于我的肚子看起来是否平坦符合快乐吗？不符合。然后，这就是“相反行动”（opposite action）变得非常有用的地方。它正如其名所暗示的那样。如果你的大脑告诉你应该再次检查你的身体，相反行动可能就是保持原状，去呼吸，去度过这种冲动，感受这种不适感升起、
and fall. This is actually called urge surfing. It's the practice of learning that feelings pass. They don't necessarily need to be acted on. Most urges last 30 to 40 minutes, and most, they always come down. Your job is not to stop the wave, it's just to like, to surf it. It's just to casually let yourself exist and live through it. Part of life and to get like just philosophical with you, probably not philosophical, just to get like Instagram poetry with you. Like part of life is to experience the joys of delicious food and yummy pastries and days where you just do nothing and getting takeout at 2am because you've been yapping to your friends all night.
达到顶峰然后消退。这实际上被称为“冲动冲浪”（urge surfing）。这是一种练习，让你明白情绪终究会过去。它们不一定需要付诸行动。大多数冲动持续 30 到 40 分钟，而且它们最终都会消退。你的工作不是去阻挡海浪，而是去驾驭它。只是随遇而安，让自己存在并经历这一切。生活的一部分——用有点哲学的话来说，大概也算不上哲学，只是想跟你来点 Instagram 式的文艺抒情——生活的一部分就是去体验美味食物的乐趣、美味糕点的快乐、什么也不做的日子、以及因为整晚和朋友聊天而在凌晨两点叫外卖的快乐。
You know, food is a source of enjoyment and joy. not discipline and punishment. Normal eating is being able to enjoy all kinds of food in moderation without feeling like you're in some kind of calorie debt or you aren't disciplined enough or this says something about your human character. It doesn't. It just says that you're having fun and that you're enjoying the fact that food is a great joy and being able to move your body in ways that you want is also a great joy and not thinking about your body so obsessively that it becomes the epicenter of your world is also a great privilege and a great joy. I want to repeat one thing that I said earlier, just one more time to finish up this episode. Skinny Talk is incredibly marvelous at marketing
你知道的，食物是享受和快乐的源泉，而不是纪律和惩罚。正常的饮食是能够适度享受各种食物，而不会觉得自己背负了某种卡路里债务、或者自己不够自律、或者这说明了你的人格有什么问题。它什么也没说明。它只说明你在享受生活，说明你正在享受食物带来的巨大快乐，并且能够以自己想要的方式活动身体也是一种巨大的快乐；同时，不必对自己的身体产生强迫性的执念，以至于它成为你世界的中心，这也是一种巨大的特权和快乐。我想把我刚才说过的一句话再重复一遍，作为这期节目的收尾。“白瘦幼言论”在营销一种生活方式方面简直妙不可言，
a kind of lifestyle that is actually probably deeply miserable and deeply unattainable. It's It's shocking. It's novel. It feeds into all these very primal archaic teen ideas of body image and how we should look and that we would be happier if we looked like this. It's also just entirely not true. So don't let yourself and your life be dominated by a trend that you see online. You have one precious, amazing, beautiful life. I just. don't think that our bodies or food is that important to be the only thing we care about. So with that in mind, we are going to wrap up this episode. If you made it this far, I want you to leave an emoji of your favorite food below. Mine's definitely a watermelon.
而这种生活方式实际上很可能深陷痛苦且遥不可及。它具有冲击力，它很新奇，它迎合了所有关于身材形象以及我们应该长成什么样子的非常原始、古老的青少年思想，让我们觉得如果我们长成这样就会更快乐。但这同时也完全是假的。所以，不要让你的生活被你在网上看到的某种潮流所主导。你拥有一段珍贵、惊艳、美丽的生命。我只是觉得我们的身体或食物并没有那么重要，不值得成为我们唯一在乎的事。带着这个想法，我们将结束这一集。如果你听到了这里，我希望你在下方留下你最喜欢的食物的表情符号。我的绝对是西瓜。
So drop yours below just so I know that you're a loyal listener and that you've made it this far on the episode. I hope that it was thought-provoking. I hope that even if you didn't agree with everything I said, that, you know, at least it got you to think more about the intersections between psychology, body, social media, gender, trends, politics. It's all just kind of like a big interconnected web when you really zone out and look at it. I want to thank, again, Libby Colbert and Aaron Somerville for their contributions to this episode and their fantastic discussions and research. Make sure that you give us a five-star review,
所以把你的留在下方，好让我知道你是一个忠实的听众，并且你已经听到了这期节目的尾声。我希望这能引发思考。我希望即使你并不同意我说的所有话，它也至少能让你更深入地思考心理学、身体、社交媒体、性别、潮流和政治之间的交织关系。当你真正跳脱出来看时，这一切其实都是一个巨大的互联网络。我要再次感谢莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）和亚伦·萨莫维尔（Aaron Somerville）对本期节目的贡献，以及他们精彩的讨论和研究。请确保给我们一个五星好评，
especially if you are listening on Apple Podcasts. It really helps the show to. grow and reach new people and reach new audiences. You can also follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to see some episode summaries, if you want to know what future episodes are coming out or just be part of the community. We would love to see you over there. But until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. Get offline every once in a while. And we will talk very, very soon. On the Look Back at a podcast. for me. 84 is big to me.
特别是如果你正在 Apple Podcasts 上收听的话。这真的对节目的成长、触及新听众和扩大受众群体非常有帮助。你也可以在 Instagram 上关注我们，账号是 That Psychology Podcast。如果你想看一些节目摘要，想知道未来会推出什么新节目，或者只是想成为这个社区的一部分。我们非常期待在那里见到你。但在此之前，请保持安全。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。偶尔远离网络。我们很快就会再聊。在《Look Back At It》播客中。对我来说，84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。我不认为还有哪一年对黑
people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kyr Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
人来说更重要了。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方订阅收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，你们好！你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《迎难而上》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都实在不够安全的坦诚对话，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
但你是在与一个懂行的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人身披盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着你有这个能力就非得这么做不可。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《迎难而上》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped.
你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的推进，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个陌生现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on. the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》？这就是 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 上的 TWO%，或者在你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。